um so at the end of our thing we do a
question you know from the internet you
can answer it what's it called it's
called
unhelpful advice so you don't have to be
helpful but this is from the email and
then you can answer it if you want to if
not you don't have to ok ok our helpful
advice with Bobby
kalila and Pauly Shore I'm a 27 year old
male who has really lost in life I have
a dead-end job still live with my
parents one which has stage 4 cancer I
have no real friends and have never
actually had a real girlfriend
I would say that things aren't really
going well for me I'm very socially
awkward and shy not talented or
intelligent in any way I wouldn't say
I'm good-looking but by any means
overall would say I'm a loser
I grew up Christian and all I hear from
people around me is trust in God and I
feel as though everyone around me is
moving up in life and getting married
and being promoted at work also I don't
have a real passion for anything anyways
what should I do
well how can I cope with my situation
really hope I get picked up love the
podcast you guys are awesome how old is
he 27 27 has he heard this is he here
this one we just heard the podcast in
general this is one we haven't heard
this one yet yeah this one's later right
okay well I live all right I'm just
saying yeah okay so you want to say I
mean I want to say you're 27 it what it
is is this is how you perceive yourself
you can change the way you look at life
right and all these things like I'm not
talented
I'm not likeable I'm ugly or whatever
you you say to yourself in your own head
that [ __ ] becomes reality eventually
right so you got to shift your
perception right it's like you are
special I don't know the guy but you can
just make a decision and go I'm going to
be positive and I'm gonna like go out
and I'm gonna do everything I can to
live a life and to perceive my life in a
different kind of way you can also
believe in the existence of God and hold
yourself accountable for all the things
that are happening ya know he's acting
like a victim you mean yeah like if
leave it up there then you'll never do
anything for yourself like he doesn't he
doesn't write your destiny for you I
mean even and even if you believe that
he does it doesn't mean that you can't
move and do things for yourself and as
far as not having a passion just throw
it throw anything on the wall and see
what sticks you know you don't have to
find it at 27 you don't have to find it
at any age but you got to get moving and
try to yeah I think them I think the
main thing is what you should know I
think you first of all the first thing
is watch is two things number one I
always say this to people number one
you're not incarcerated uh-huh so that's
the first thing why it's like a mess in
lockup watch these shows my favorite
show
see that's the [ __ ] I watch I don't
watch Game of Thrones it's a really good
between well you asked me what I liked
sorry but I like it this is one of the
greatest things ever made if you don't
wanna watch it that's all bad on you my
friend okay all right so let's try to
help this guy from so anyway so so
number one be happy you're not
incarcerated watch and mess in lockup
and number two and number two you
[ __ ] can walk okay and you're healthy
and you can walk out of your house and
you have two [ __ ] legs and you can
feed yourself you know I mean just [ __ ]
like that you know what I mean look at
what you have and not what you don't
have and stop being a [ __ ] victim you
know there's people that are way more
[ __ ] up than you that are doing
awesome
stop being woe is me yeah and you know
change your standards marriage he says
he's looking at his friends we're
getting married and don't compare
yourself to other people you know Bobby
compared himself to other people like
that what's that Asian actor that's
always in all these movies Randall Park
[ __ ] hung yourself a long time ago in
the thing you don't you're like you're
Bobby Reed that's who you are you'd be
happy with that
well because you what you what you I do
is this is that I mean there was a time
where I was jealous but then you go I'm
not him
I you know we're not the same if you
want my flavor in your [ __ ] then you're
gonna get it but it's like I'm not him
and he's not me just because your eyes
are a certain way right and you know
that's true just like I'm not screech
you know what I mean it's the same thing
you're not right pay your own way
[ __ ] your friends yeah yeah don't don't
listen to other people don't compare
yourself to other people and look at
what you have not what you don't have
please Jesus
I'm praised [ __ ] Jesus yeah
[Music]